hello I'm Anne I live in Europe I'm 21
years old and I'm writing a blog based
on Eurostat statistics about sustainable
development follow me and I'll show you
how close desire to our everyday life I
came up with the idea for the blog when
my grandfather showed me his new
pesticide free garden he told me how
much organic farming in the EU was
expanding in 2014 alone an area the size
of Luxembourg came organic I had never
realized that when we dropped his
recycling off with a new recycling
center my grandpa told me that in 2014
434 kilograms per tonne of municipal
waste was recycled that's 51 kilograms
more than in 2010 recycling allows us to
produce more without harming nature
that evening we heard in the news that
in 2015 the GDP per capita in the EU has
for the first time exceeded its
pre-crisis value reaching 26 thousand
three hundred euro yet great differences
remain between EU countries
unfortunately the benefits of economic
growth are not evenly distributed
between 2010 and 2014
income inequality between the richest
20% and the poorest 20% of EU citizens
remained relatively constant with the
richest earning 5 times more than the
poorest this income inequality cuts
through society
inequality also exists between genders
particularly regarding pay take my
friend Marta she has a good job and is
well paid however in general women have
jobs that are paid less than men in 2014
a woman earned an average of only 84
cent per hour for every euro paid for
man as Marta FFA's education and
training can contribute to close this
gap more and more women are attaining
university degrees and they do so more
than men the same is true for lifelong
learning activities
and while writing this vlog I'm learning
to at least European statistics are not
just abstract numbers but part of our
everyday life indeed and story shows
that Eurostar sustainable development
indicators are relevant for everyday
lives of EU citizens to find out more
read our publications on sustainable
development and visit our website
you